[موسيقى]
للمره العاشره على التوالي وخلال اربع
سنوات فقط تتشكل حكومه جديده في الفيروس
تستحكم اول رئيسه في تاريخ البلاد 17
وزيرا من الاختصاصيين الدولي من الدستوريه
في محاوله لتجنب مصير الحكومات السابقه
الذي اقيلت او استقالت نتيجه ازمه الحكم
المعقده
التي يعاني منها وطننا وقد اتينا اليكم
نمد ايدينا للعمل على ايجاد حل واستعاده
الاستقرار
منذ لحظه ولادتها لم تسلم هذه التشكيله
الحكوميه من الانتقادات في شكلها واسمائها
رغم اتفاق البيروفيين على انها جنبت
البلاد الفراغ
في الوقت الذي اعلنت فيه الحكومه الجديده
في البيرو يرى مؤيد الرئيس المعزول تدر
كاسيو ان الخطوه تزيد من تعقيد المشهد
السياسي ويوصلنا احتجاجاتهم في العاصمه
وعموم البلاد رفضا لاجراءات رئيسه المؤقته
المطالبه بالاعلان عن تنظيم الانتخابات
مبكرا
عند ساحه الاحتجاجات الرئاسيه وسط
العاصمهما في مستقبل مختلف لبلدهما
نحن شباب نريد ان تسود الديمقراطيه بلدنا
نريد اجراء انتخابات مبكرا وتغيير
البرلمان الذي لا يشبهنا ولا يمثلنا
يؤيدها في ذلك محتاجون من مختلف الاعمار
يرفعون مطالبا مشابها ويتوعدون بالاحتكام
الى الشارع ما لم يتم تنفيذها واولها
الافراج عن رئيسهم المعتقل ما يضع البلاد
امام سيناريوهات مختلفه براي مختصين
التي تضم اختصاصيين كثيرا من حل المشكلات
المريحه للمواطنين فتستمر ويسود الاستقرار
اما الثاني فهو استمرار هذه الاحتجاجات
وتوسعها لتسقط الحكومه ونعود للمربع صفر
الذي قد يحتاج الى اعاده النظر في الدستور
اسباب ازمات البلاد ومصيرها باتت على كل
لسان هنا يتبادلها هؤلاء الاراء حول
واقعهم ويتمنون الا تفرقهم السياسه
اصبحت لدينا عاده الا يستطيع الرؤساء
الاستمرار وهذا كله بسبب الفساد نحتاج الى
استعاده الثقه فقط فقدنا الثقه فيه
ان خورخي فيتابع اخر اخبار بلده بقلق ويرى
ان الحل يكمن في تغيير العقليات السياسيه
[موسيقى]
يتمنى البيروفيون ان تنتهي نغمه عزل
واستقاله الرؤساء اعل البهجه تعود الى
حياه سكان بلاد حضاره الانكا من جديد حسن
مسعود الجزيره ليما